un concert en cette période et bien oui
c'est possible le groupe musique de pine
apple s'est produit sur les planches du
temps machine à joué les tours mais sans
public le concert a été diffusée en
direct sur les ondes de radio béton
les auditeurs ont pu en profiter pendant
une heure premier de quatre concerts à
l'initiative de la radio en soutien au
musicien paul moyenne nous c'est bye
d'apple ouais on est super contents
jouable ici ce soir
ce trio local plein d'énergie s'est
produit hier soir sur les planches du
temps machine à joué-lès-tours leur
musique un mélange de rock l anglaise et
de techno bien pêchue habitué aux salles
bondées
c'est la première fois que ces jeunes
jouent devant une salle complètement
vide
c'est intéressant de le faire j'ai pas
envie de m'habituer à ça mais c'est cool
de le faire j'espère que ça va être une
idée qui voyait un petit coup de l'apéro
avec nous et puis que ça tape du pied à
la maison pourquoi pas durant une heure
le groupe a chanté ses meilleurs titres
julie auchan mehdi au synthétiseur et
arnaud à la guitare le tout diffusé en
direct sur les ondes de radio béton
une expérience qui n'aurait pas été
possible sans le coup de pouce d'enzo
pétillot il y avait pas mal de choses
qui se mettait en place
films et vidéos diffusées sur les
réseaux sociaux et nous notre média
principal ça reste la radio donc on a eu
envie de mettre en valeur avec ça le
bémol pas de public mais chaque
spectateur peut vivre le concert de chez
lui un concert qui fait du bien aux
artistes mais cela cache bel et bien un
ras-le-bol du monde de la culture pour
odorantes rhumel directeur du temps
machine accepté ce concert était une
évidence mais le jeune homme espère que
ce ne serait que provisoire à la fois
évidemment d'abord avec les artistes qui
sont les premières lignes dans les
difficultés en ce moment puisqu'ils
peuvent pas diffusé on essaie d aider
pour faire leur travail mais ils peuvent
préparer les concerts dont on ne sait
pas ce qu'ils auront lieu c'est hyper
difficile y compris moralement sans
parler évidemment les côtés économiques
de l'heure
leur survie radio béton organisera trois
autres concerts diffusés en direct sur
les ondes dans les prochaines semaines
ils auront lieu à l'espace malraux au
théâtre olympia et enfin au bateau ivre
d'ici là le groupe pineapple vous dis à
bientôt
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]